[Musik]
auf dem 20 Parteitag der chinesischen KP
im Oktober des letzten Jahres hat Regime
pink die Chinesen eingeschworen auf
harte Zeiten und von großen Problemen
gesprochen die auf dem Weg liegen was
hat er damit gemeint damit hat er
gemeint dass die Chinesen sich bei
diesem großen Aufstieg den sie hinter
sich haben
weiterhin zusammenreißen sollen also
dass sie jetzt nicht glauben sollen es
sei schon alles erreicht nach 40 Jahren
Aufstieg sondern dass man sozusagen erst
den halben Weg gegangen ist und nun
weiter schauen muss dass China wirklich
zu einer Welt macht aufsteigt hat er das
nur wirtschaftspolitisch gemeint oder
hat er am Horizont eine sich
verschaffende Auseinandersetzung mit den
USA und mit Europa gesehen naja am
Horizont ist gut diese verschärfende
Auseinandersetzung gibt es ja tagtäglich
schon ein der Machtkampf zwischen der
aufsteigenden Weltmacht und der
etablierten oder der amtierenden
Weltmacht USA
der ist ja täglich schon da insofern
muss man das glaube ich den Leuten gar
nicht sagen
aber
er hat natürlich sozusagen schon die
Sorge dass die Leute zu bequem werden
dass sie unter Umständen glauben dass
alles
kommt von selber dieser wirtschaftliche
Aufstieg und Sie müssen sich nicht
sozusagen selber einbringen das gilt vor
allem für die Küstenregionen und die
Leute ja schon relativ weit entwickelt
sind und auch schon darüber nachdenken
wie eine Work-Life-Balance aussehen kann
also wie man
das die Lebensqualität und die
Arbeitszeit in ein vernünftiges
Verhältnis bringt
wir haben bei uns auf dem gegenwärtigen
Stand unseres Wirtschaftens unserer
Politik viele Überlegungen die in die
Richtung gehen
Postwachstumsgesellschaft
Work-Life-Balance kann diese gerade
angesprochen haben die Frage nach dem
Sinn wird wichtiger als die Frage nach
der Arbeit um jeden Preis die Frage nach
der Nachhaltigkeit wichtiger als die des
wohlstandswachstums solche Diskussionen
werden in China inzwischen auch geführt
ja selbstverständlich die Politik hat
sich gerade umgestellt von Wachstum auf
jeden Preis in Richtung nachhaltiges
Wachstum das ist ein ganz wichtiger
politischer Schritt der ausdrücklich
bedeutet nicht mehr Wachstum um jeden
Preis sondern diese großen Themen Klima
Themen
die werden jetzt sozusagen mit
eingepreist und
die Wirtschaft wird entsprechend
umgebaut damit sie nachhaltiger wird sie
haben viele Bücher über China
geschrieben und in einem sehr
umfangreichen Buch
über die Zukunft und über China dass sie
2018 geschrieben haben
versuchen sie zu zeigen wie sie Welt
sich in einem Übergang befindet von
einer
vollständig von den USA dominierten 20
Jahrhundert zu einer multipolaren
Weltordnung im 21 Jahrhundert wollen Sie
mal kurz in wesentlichen Zügen
beschreiben was diese
Veränderungsdynamik aus ihrer Sicht ist
ja das kann man eigentlich ganz einfach
sagen eine Epoche geht zu Ende nämlich
die Epoche in der die Minderheit des
Westens zunächst waren es die Europäer
bis Mitte des 20 Jahrhunderts dann die
Amerikaner also ein Epoche in der die
Minderheit des Westens die Spielregeln
der Mehrheit der Welt bestimmen konnte
das war die Regel in den vergangenen
Jahrhunderten und es sieht ganz danach
aus als ob diese Epoche zu Ende geht
zugunsten einer multipolaren Weltordnung
in der die aussteigenden Länder China
Indien aber auch Afrika nicht zu
vergessen immer mehr in der Lage sind
alleine ihre Entscheidung zu treffen und
nicht mehr von den Entscheidungen den
Spielregeln des Westens abhängig sind
sie beschreiben in dieser Hinsicht die
Amerikaner und die Europäer mit dem Adel
ja der irgendwann einsehen muss dass
nicht eine Minderheit über eine Mehrheit
entscheiden kann sie beziehen das auf
die globale Weltsituation und sagt die
Minderheit des Westens bestimmt die
zentralen Spielregeln überall auf diesem
Planeten militärisch zu einem nicht
unerheblichen Teil nach wie vor
wirtschaftlich Finanzmärkte zum Beispiel
sie dominiert die großen Organisationen
Welthandelsorganisation die Weltbank und
das ist doofer eigentlich nicht so sein
weil wenn man von den westlichen Werten
überzeugt ist dann ist man ja davon
überzeugt one-man one wood ja also jeder
hat eine Stimme und wer mehr Menschen
hat er hat auch mehr Stimmen und dann
müsste ein Fünftel der Weltbevölkerung
die in China lebt 1,4 Milliarden
Menschen ein ganz anderes Gewicht in der
Welt bekommen als das was China bisher
hat
davor fürchten sich allerdings auch
viele und Denken na ja also mit One Man
one wo das sehen wir außenpolitisch
irgendwie nicht so wie wir das
innenpolitisch sehen und das ist eben
das große Problem ich glaube dass es
eine Schwerkraft in diese Richtung geht
genauso wie es im 19 Jahrhundert eine
Schwerkraft gab gegen den Adel als die
Bürger in den Nationalstaaten gesagt
haben es war schön mit euch lieber
Adeligen aber wir wollen jetzt selbst
entscheiden und mein Eindruck ist das
wir uns gerade global gesehen genau in
einem ähnlichen Prozess befinden und ich
sehe nicht dass der Westen noch die
Kraft hat
sein Monopol die Spielregeln zu
bestimmen durchzuhalten sondern gerade
in den letzten zwei drei Jahren hat sich
ganz deutlich gezeigt dass immer mehr
Länder unabhängig ihre Interessen und
ihre Vorstellungen vertreten wollen und
das nun tatsächlich eine multipolare
Weltordnung entsteht und unser Dilemma
ist dass wir einerseits von unseren
Werten überzeugt sind als die Adligen
der Welt und andererseits die aber auch
zugeben müssen dass der Zustand dass die
Minderheit die Spielregel der
Mehrheit bestimmt nicht unseren
Wertvorstellungen entspricht und in
diesem Dilemma befinden wir uns gerade
und versuchen
es dadurch uns ein bisschen
Einfahrt zu machen dass wir die
sozusagen dass wir uns selber an Kosten
unserer Gruppe messen und die Aufsteiger
an den schlechtesten ihrer Gruppe und
dann sagen na ja die sind noch nicht so
weit die brauchen noch unsere Fürsorge
es ist ja ein gewaltiger
Umdenkungsprozess vor dem wir
diesbezüglich stehen also ich hatte hier
vor einiger Zeit Francis Fukuyama zu
Gast
Fukuyama wurde berühmt mit der These vom
Ende der Geschichte also hegelsformel
vom Ende der Geschichte angewendet auf
die Zeit nach dem Zusammenbruch des
Staatssozialismus er hat also gesagt
jetzt hier 1991 92 nach dem
Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion nach dem
Fall der Mauer 89 sehen wir es gibt nur
ein richtig überlegenes System das sind
die liberalen Demokratien und
Kapitalismus und liberale Demokratie
zusammen sind das beste System was die
Menschheit hier gekannt hat und jetzt
ist es nur noch eine Frage der Zeit bis
die ganze Welt irgendwann aus solchen
gut funktionierenden liberald
demokratischen kapitalistischen Systemen
besteht das haben wir ziemlich lange
gerne gekauft und jetzt sehen wir ist
die erfolgreichste Wirtschaftsnation der
Welt wenn man sich den Aufstieg in den
letzten Jahrzehnten anguckt eine
Mischung aus Kommunismus und
Raubtierkapitalismus ist und das ist
dort keine liberale Demokratie geht das
heißt also unser fester Glaube
Kommunisten können nicht erfolgreich
wirtschaften der hat sich jetzt ins
Gegenteil verkehren müssen dass das zu
einer großen Verunsicherung beim Westen
führt ist ja zunächst mal verständlich
kann man die produktiv machen diese
Verunsicherung was müssen wir jetzt
lernen wir müssen lernen die Welt aus
der Perspektive dieser Aussteiger zu
sehen das ist eigentlich ganz einfach
die haben eben andere Vorstellungen ob
China jetzt wirklich kommunistisch ist
darüber könnten wir uns lange
unterhalten oder auch einen kleinen
Vorschlag dazu ja gerne also mein
Vorschlag wäre Karl Marx hat den
Kommunismus so definiert ein Maximum an
politischer Freiheit bei einem Minimum
an wirtschaftlicher Freiheit
china hat ein Maximum an
wirtschaftlicher Freiheit bei einem
Minimum an politischer Freiheit also im
Grunde genommen ist es das Gegenteil von
Kommunismus
ja das ist eine faszinierende Erklärung
man könnte es aber auch einfach sein
noch einfacher machen und sagen wie
Chinesen sind am Ende pragmatisch und
das wichtigste für China ist eigentlich
dass es wieder das Reich der Mitte wird
das ist wieder eine Weltmacht wird die
ist schon mal war und die Ideologie ist
eigentlich nur ein Mittel zum Zweck und
wenn die sozusagen Ideologie dem
Aufstieg im Wege stünde weil man zum
Beispiel
auf
Staats ähm Betrieben bestehen würde
dann und das hat man in der Geschichte
Chinas gesehen dann würde man sagen na
ja das funktioniert so nicht das müssen
wir korrigieren und so hat es eine
marktwirtschaftliche Öffnung gegeben die
eigentlich mit den kommunistischen
Vorstellungen nicht so viel zu tun hat
sie würden chinesischen Führung gibt es
eigentlich gar keine überzeugten
Kommunisten
ich glaube die das ist zu viel gesagt
wieder ich glaube es gibt etwas was
wichtiger ist und
das wichtigste ist das China wieder das
wird was es einmal war nach diesen 150
Jahren Pleiten Pech und Pannen man hat
aus einer Mischung aus Arroganz und
Überheblichkeit im 19 Jahrhundert mal
eben die industrielle Revolution in
Europa unterschätzt
ignoriert und ist dadurch in große
wirtschaftliche Schwierigkeiten geraten
der Mao hat es dann im letzten Moment
alles wieder zusammengehalten das Land
aber China hat es aus eigener Kraft
nicht mehr geschafft
wirtschaftlich aufzusteigen Mao hat ja
diese
brutalen Kampagnen
durchs Land gejagt in der Hoffnung oder
von der Überzeugung getragen dass China
das aus eigener Kraft das reicht der
Mitte das ist eigen oft schaffen würde
aber das war nicht so und dann musste
sein Nachfolger kommen der denkt jaoping
und er hatte erstmal eine ganz bittere
Nachricht der hat nämlich so ein
Landsleuten gesagt wir sind zu schwach
wir schaffen das nicht mehr alleine wir
müssen uns von den Imperialisten von den
Kapitalisten helfen lassen und das ist
genau dieser Pragmatismus
der dieses Land ausmacht und der
wahrscheinlich eines der
Erfolgsgeheimnisse ist dass man eben
nicht in der Ideologie stecken bleibt
sondern
die Entwicklung immer den pragmatischen
Erfordernissen anpasst das heißt nicht
dass es nicht doch ideologische
Dispositionen gibt die wir dann auch
kommunistisch nennen können über die man
nicht hinauskommt aber am Ende ist das
wichtigste dieser Aufstieg
das ist also sozusagen die die Erklärung
das auch der Kommunismus in China einem
übergeordneten Pragmatismus
untergeordnet ist das auch so mit dem
berühmten chinesischen Konfuzianismus
also die die Vorstellung dass es ein ein
Gemeinsinn geben muss ein ein
metaphysisches wertekonzept was
gemeinsam geteilt werden muss so als
eine Art gegen gegen die
Ellbogengesellschaft und den
Kapitalismus hat ja den Konfuzianismus
wieder belebt ja der lange Zeit auch
verpönt war in China braucht man
sozusagen das als Zuckerguss auf dem
Kuchen damit er nicht auseinander fällt
die Frage ist ja um was geht es da am
Ende und am Ende geht es um ein anderes
Verhältnis zwischen Individuum und
Gemeinschaft das ist eigentlich die also
Kapitalismus und Konfuzianismus beißen
sich doch eigentlich oder eigentlich
schon ja aber die Chinesen kriegen das
hin also sozusagen auf der einen Seite
also diese die Ellbogen Gesellschaft der
die sozusagen dem Wohl der Gesellschaft
ist nur gedient durch den Egoismus des
Einzelnen sozusagen die Erfolgsformel
des Kapitalismus von Adam Smith auf der
einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite
dieses sich nicht über die anderen
Stellen in der Werte Harmonie ja wie
geht das in China zusammen ja Chinesisch
Politiker würden sagen genau das ist
unser Job
das auszutabieren das ist sozusagen die
der entscheidende Punkt also auf der
einen Seite
marktwirtschaftlich Individualismus
zulassen weil man verstanden hat dass
Innovation überhaupt nur so möglich ist
über den marktwirtschaftlichen
Wettbewerb der wirtschaftlich gefördert
wird
auf der einen Seite auf der anderen
Seite schauen dass sozusagen
die Individuen die erfolgreichen
Individuum auch die Interessen der
Gemeinschaft nicht aushebeln
das ist ja jetzt so in der Beschreibung
hört sich das ja sehr positiv an und bis
zum gewissen gerade wird ein
konservative deutsche Politiker sagen
das ist eigentlich gut und richtig wir
wollen das auch wir wollen auf der einen
Seite erfolgreichen Kapitalismus und auf
der anderen Seite wollen wir Werte
Traditionen wir bei uns wird überall
beklagt der gemein sind geht verloren ja
in der Turbo kapitalistischen
Gesellschaft wird ja auch von
konservativer Seite also etwas relativ
ähnliches gleichzeitig schauen wir aber
auf China eigentlich nicht als sagen wir
die haben ja ähnliche Probleme wie wir
sondern die sind eigentlich ganz anders
und die sind eine elementare Bedrohung
für unser Wertesystem und Stichwort was
er dafür benutzen ist Menschenrechte es
gibt keine Pressefreiheit in China es
gibt die Unterdrückung von Minderheiten
wie die Uhren es gibt sehr viel
Eingriffe in die private Freiheit die
bei uns recht staatlich nicht möglich
wäre wären es gibt sehr harte Justiz und
so weiter und so weiter also es gibt
viele Dinge die wir in China aus unserem
die Werte Bewusstsein heraus kritisieren
finden Sie dass es richtig und legitim
dass wir das tun der selbstverständlich
aber gleichzeitig sagen sie auch wir
sollten dabei nicht so arrogant
auftreten
ja das ist ja klar also Arroganz heißt
ja im Grunde Postkolonialismus das heißt
wir sagen unsere unsere Vorstellung ist
die richtige und ihr liebe Chinesen
müsst dahin kommen wo wir schon sind ich
glaube das ist aber nicht mehr zeitgemäß
wir können die Chinesen nicht mehr
zwingen auch die chinesische Regierung
nicht mit zwingend das zu tun was wir
wollen was wir aber können und müssen
Sie von unseren Werten und
Wertvorstellungen zu überzeugen wir
müssen in einen Dialog führen wir müssen
das ist leider umständlich aber das
machen wir in der Demokratie eigentlich
sowieso schon jeden Tag aber sehen Sie
auf chinesischer Seite
Gesprächsbereitschaft natürlich okay
wenn wenn es nicht von oben herab kommt
wenn es nicht arrogant ist die haben
dann sind natürlich sehr empfindlich
dafür was in welcher in welchem Ton
diese ehemaligen Kolonien Kolonialherren
mit ihnen reden und China war ja zum
kolonialisiert von den Europäern von
Amerikanern
das ist heißt aber nicht dass man sie
nicht überzeugen kann von bestimmten
Dingen sie haben sogar das europäische
Datenschutzgesetz übernommen fast eins
zu eins weil sie gesagt haben das macht
Sinn praktizieren das auch naja sie
praktizieren es im Verhältnis
Konsumenten und Unternehmen und sie
Praktizierens ich würde fast sagen
natürlich noch nicht im Verhältnis
Individuum und Staat der Staat nimmt
sich da fein raus und zum Beispiel ist
es jetzt unsere Aufgabe zu erklären
warum das auf Dauer keine gute Sache ist
wenn wir aber versuchen sozusagen
einfach durch Sanktionen
die chinesene an bestimmte Richtung zu
zwingen wird das einfach nicht mehr
funktionieren weil dazu sind sie schon
zu stark und
zu selbstständig für Politiker für
westliche Politiker ist es natürlich
einfach Sanktionen zu verhängen das ist
viel einfacher als zu überzeugen aber
wir müssen uns immer die Frage stellen
zum Beispiel bei der bei dem Thema
shinjang wie geht man mit der
muslimischen Minderheit um in Hongkong
wie geht man mit der Bürgerbewegung dort
um viele andere Themen Zensur sie haben
es gerade angesprochen wir müssen uns
eigentlich die Frage stellen was können
wir tun damit sich die Situation der
Menschen die unter diesen
Umständen leiden verbessert jetzt mal
dazu dass die
Datenschutzregeln für das Verhältnis von
Konsument und Unternehmen gelten dass
sie aber nicht im Verhältnis zu dem
Staat gelten eines der größten
Schreckgespenster chinesischer
Innenpolitik ist das Social creditsystem
jetzt habe ich dafür in meinem Leben so
viel Widersprüchliches gehört also
dieses dass man hingeht und seine
Bevölkerung überwacht und dass sie eine
gewisse Punkteanzahl haben und dass sie
diese Punkte verlieren können wenn sie
regeln Verstöße machen und sich daneben
benehmen wird das praktiziert nein das
waren Pilotversuche das hat man
ausprobiert das ist aber gar nicht so
sehr die Frage ob es das schon gibt
ähm oder nicht die Frage ist ist denkbar
und da muss man Antworten ja mit den
neuen technologischen Mitteln und ist es
erwartbar dass die chinesische Regierung
das ich glaube man hat das in Shanghai
getestet also man hat mehrere kleine
Feldversuche gemacht es ist aber
es ist bisher erstaunlicherweise
nicht zentral ausgerollt worden und es
ist auch so das Thema ist ein bisschen
im Sande verlaufen das heißt aber nicht
dass man darüber nicht reden muss und
dass man vor den Risiken waren muss die
die dabei entstehen und die vielleicht
in China auch in der Bevölkerung
unterschätzt werden angesichts der neuen
technologischen Möglichkeiten die diese
vielen Kameras auch bieten die das
elektronische Bezahlen mit dem
Smartphone über wechat bieten und so
weiter und so fort
auch da
müssen wir mit unseren Vorstellungen und
auch unserer Geschichte einfach in den
Dialog treten und
vor Risiken warnen also der
funktionieren ja offensichtlich
umgekehrt also wir sind relativ einfach
bereit große Risiken einzugehen wenn es
um Unternehmen geht aber relativ wollen
nicht dass der Staat in unserer
Privatsphäre fällt und China praktiziert
es jetzt sozusagen eine umgekehrt also
bei den Unternehmen ist die Sensibilität
möglicherweise sogar höher als bei uns
aber gegenüber dem Staat sagt man ne ne
ne Moment das ist wichtig und das hat
voran wie wird das von der chinesischen
Bevölkerung denn selber empfunden
ja die haben natürlich was heißt
natürlich sie haben ein anderes
Verhältnis zu dem Staat als wir glauben
weil sie diesen 40 Jahre Aufstieg hinter
sich haben für sie ist der Staat jetzt
muss kann man das natürlich nicht auf
jeden und alle pauschalisieren aber für
die Mehrheit ist der Staat
eine Institution der diesen der diesen
Aufstieg gemanagt hat also wir haben auf
der einen Seite diese Riesen
Erfolgsgeschichte sehr viele Menschen
aus bitterer Armut befreit zu haben aber
wir sind natürlich immer noch Lichtjahre
in in Ländern wie Deutschland auch USA
und so weiter entfernt was den
durchschnittlichen Lebensstandard der
Bevölkerung anbelangt und auch was
bestimmte Freiheiten betrifft wenn wir
uns die Pressezensur angucken wenn es
darum geht dass die Partei und der Staat
jederzeit in das Rechtssystem eingreifen
können das Rechtssystem hat sich
dramatisch verbessert aber diese
Eingriffsmöglichkeit der Politik den
Rechtsstaat die Möglichkeit den
Rechtsstaat auszuhebeln ist immer noch
da und ich glaube was wir lernen müssen
ist dass es eben beides gibt
diese noch
starken Einschränkungen bei den
persönlichen Freiheiten auf der einen
Seite und auf der anderen Seite diese
unglaubliche
Zunahme an persönlichem Freiraum und wir
müssen lernen das gleichzeitig zu denken
und zu sehen und wenn wir das nicht tun
dann schätzen wir China falsch ein und
dann entwickeln wir auch falsche
Strategien im Umgang mit diesen neuen
aufsteigen sie benutzen das Wort noch ja
also sie sagen noch gibt es quasi starke
Einschränkungen auf der juristischen
Ebene noch gibt es diese starken
Eingriffsmöglichkeiten des Staates in
die menschliche Privatsphäre dieses noch
hört sich doch nach Fukuyama an also das
hört sich so an als wenn sie sagen
würden naja gut die Chinesen sind jetzt
in einer gigantischen aufholen Rallye
die wird auch noch vielleicht 10 oder 20
Jahre anhalten und dann wird der
Lebensstandard so gestiegen sein dass
der logische nächste Prozess ist dass
sie zu ähnlichen Freiheitsrechten
werden wie im Westen glauben Sie das so
ja sind ja auch Menschen ja und die
werden mit einer gewissen Entwicklungs
Reife bestimmte Freiheiten einfordern ob
man jetzt so sagen kann das sind nur
zehn oder 20 Jahre oder ob es länger
dauert das ist eine Frage die sehr
schwierig zu beantworten ist weil das in
1,4 Milliarden Menschen da gibt es
Menschen die leben noch wie im 19
Jahrhundert und andere die Leben im
diesen im Grunde weiter als wir im 21
Jahrhundert in in südina in shinjin dem
neuen Silicon Valley darüber habe ich
mein letztes Buch geschrieben da sind
viele Dinge schon viel moderner das und
und das bedeutet auch dass diese
Menschen in diesen Regionen größere
Freiheiten beanspruchen und auch
bekommen als in den rückständigeren
Region
aber ich glaube die Entwicklungsrichtung
ist
ist ist ähnlich wie im Westen mit einer
wichtigen Einschränkung
ich vermute dass es immer ein anderes
Verhältnis geben wird zwischen
Individuum und Gemeinschaft weil das ist
etwas was ich durch alle asiatischen
Gesellschaften durchzieht auch durch
sehr erwachsene Demokratien wie Japan
Südkorea
das Interesse an der Gemeinschaft oder
das Interesse sich als Individuum
im Sinne Gemeinschaft zurückzunehmen ist
also die Größe irgendwann Japan werden
das würde ich wie Deutschland das wird
Japan
ja ich weiß gar nicht glaube ich China
wird was ganz eigenes und wir müssen mit
diesen Vergleichen vorsichtig sein
weil ich China ist auch kein Modell für
andere Länder weil es so ungewöhnlich
ist also die Größe auf der einen Seite
dann es war schon mal Weltmacht es war
schon mal ähm ein Land das die
Innovation der Welt vorangebracht hat
das sind alles sozusagen
große Unterschiede zu anderen Ländern zu
Indien wo die Situation ganz anders ist
Indien ist ein im Grunde künstlich
geschaffen das Gebilde hat ganz andere
Probleme es wirtschaftlich viel weiter
zurück wir müssen lernen glaube ich
China als den chinesischen
Entwicklungsweg als ein eigenständigen
zu begreifen und wir müssen verstehen
wie dieser Entwicklungsweg aussieht weil
sonst können wir
unsere Strategien nicht entsprechend
anpassen weil für uns geht es ja darum
dass wir möglichst viel dessen was uns
lieb und teuer ist an Werten in diese
neue Weltordnung mit einbringen früher
haben wir an dem Tisch hat uns der Tisch
gehört an dem die Spielregeln der Welt
vereinbart wurden und wir haben
entschieden wer daran sitzt erst die
Europäer dann in der zweiten Hälfte des
20 Jahrhunderts die Amerikaner heute ist
es nicht mehr so heute haben die
Europäer nicht mehr automatisch einen
Platz an diesem Tisch
und deswegen ist auch diese Alternative
Werte oder Wirtschaft eine Alternative
die einen in die falsche Richtung lenkt
weil nur wenn wir wirtschaftlich stark
sind
spielen wir überhaupt noch eine Rolle
wenn es darum geht
im
die neuen Spielregeln der Weltordnung
die Werte der Weltordnung zu vereinbaren
militärisch spielen wie keine Rolle in
Europa also bleibt uns nur die
wirtschaftliche Stärke wenn wir
wirtschaftlich keine Rolle spielen wird
uns niemand mehr an den Tisch bitten nur
ist es ja interessant sie erzählen die
Geschichte jetzt von China im Verhältnis
zum Westen als die Geschichte eines
Aufsteigers ja der jetzt in dem Club der
etablierten aufsteigt und der ohne
Zweifel gekommen ist um zu bleiben ja
und sich auch immer größere Scheibe vom
Kuchen abschneiden schon mal da war und
hat China nun hat China enorm profitiert
von der Globalisierung nicht nur dass
sie Chinesen ihre Produkte überall
verkaufen und alles Kirche für uns
herstellen und auch eigene Produkte mehr
und mehr herstellen wir verkaufen von
zehn Autos die in Deutschland gebaut
werden werden vier nach China verkauft
das heißt also auf der Westen ist immer
abhängiger geworden von China jetzt
erleben wir gerade eine politische
Situation in der ausgelöst durch den
Ukraine Krieg eigentlich die bipolare
Weltordnung weder das große Thema ist
das heißt also aus der Sicht Washingtons
aber das auch das narrativ der Europäer
befinden wir uns jetzt in einem Kampf
zwischen den westlichen Demokratien und
den pauschal sogenannten autoquartier
das ist dann Russland und China und so
weiter alles mehr oder weniger dasselbe
und das ist wieder eine bipolare
Weltordnung Kapitalismus gegen
Kommunismus gewesen ist aber das im
Augenblick große narrativ es ist nicht
die Geschichte von etablierten und
Aufsteigern sondern es ist westliches
Wertesystem gegen Autokratie
in Asien ist der Gedanke des Aufsteigens
ist stärker als der Gedanke oder der
Unterschied Demokratie oder Autokratie
Asien hat sich gerade zu einer der
größten Freihandelszone der Welt
zusammengefunden das sind selbst die
Australier mit drin die sich mit den
Chinesen streiten da sind die Japaner
mit drin die Inder sind übrigens noch
nicht drin die die sozusagen haben aber
schon gesagt die Tür ist nicht zu
aber da haben sich ganz unterschiedliche
Länder
mit ganz unterschiedlichen politischen
Systemen und unterschiedlichen
entwicklungsständen und
unterschiedlichen Religionen und
unterschiedlichen Größen zu einer
Freihandelszone zusammengetan
unter einem Stichwort und das lautet wir
sind die Aufsteiger das heißt es ist
also sozusagen in der Perspektive egal
ob ein Land demokratisch autokratisch
oder wie auch automatisch
Gefühl für Europa wichtig ist also die
sozusagen im Verhältnis zwischen
Südkorea und China ist eben das Thema
zusammen aufzusteigen stärker als das
Thema dass die Südkoreaner eine
Demokratie sind und die Chinesen ein
autoritäres System das heißt nicht dass
man alles gut findet als Nachbarland was
China macht das bedeutet auch nicht dass
man an mulmiges Gefühl hat angesichts
dieses Riesen der sich im
Südchinesischen Meer immer stärker
ausbreitet und eine Insel frech eine
Insel nach der anderen
besetzt und ähm zu chinesischen
terrorium erklärt
aber am Ende
siegt doch der Pragmatismus und man
entschließt sich zusammenzuarbeiten weil
man dieses Gefühl des Aufsteigens teilt
und weil man ein Gefühl teilt das jetzt
immer sichtbarer wird nämlich dass man
selbst Entscheidungen treffen kann ohne
vom Westen in die eine oder in die
andere Richtung gezwungen zu werden und
das ist natürlich ein
ein ein
Selbstbewusstsein das da entsteht dass
ich jetzt immer stärker manifestiert ich
möchte das weil das ist eine Frage die
mich auch sehr beschäftigt noch mal ein
bisschen vertiefen
mein Eindruck war oder ist dass wir in
einem Globalisierungsprozess so wie sie
das auch beschrieben haben und jetzt
beschreiben in eine multipolare
Weltordnung übergehen werden in
selbstverständlich eine Land wie China
mit 1,4 Milliarden Menschen und einer
zunehmenden Wirtschaftskraft ein
größeren beansprucht was ja übrigens
dann nicht schlimm wäre wenn der Kuchen
größer würde ja also wenn es sozusagen
nicht auf Kosten des Wohlstandes ist ja
eine Frage wo man lange drüber
diskutieren kann ob das so ist oder ob
das nicht so ist ja so das war jetzt
sozusagen die klassische Erzählung jetzt
haben wir den Ukraine krieg jetzt haben
wir das narrativ der Kampf der
westlichen Demokratien gegen die
Autokratien und meine Befürchtung ist
dass wir jetzt über die nächste Zeit in
eine restaurationsphase kommen das also
so ähnlich wie es kommt die Erklärung
der Menschenrechte die Französische
Revolution und Napoleon erzählt den
Menschen in Europa ihr könnt euch alle
befreien und selbstbestimmt werden und
wir bringen euch eine moderne
Rechtsprechung und und und und darauf
folgt der Wiener Kongress und dann wird
das ganze noch mal wieder das alte
adelsystem wird also noch mal wieder
neue restauriert und ich denke so ein
bisschen wir sind eigentlich im 21
Jahrhundert auf dem Weg in die
multipolare Weltordnung und versuchen
aber jetzt eigentlich die bipolare Welt
des 20 Jahrhunderts wieder also das West
ergänzt the rest ja wieder zu etablieren
und jetzt war das World Economic Forum
in Davos da vielen Begriffe wie
degglobalisierung ja oder
fragmentarisierung der Welt also da ist
scheint so zu mir aus der westlicher
Perspektive der Schwung oder die
Hoffnung ja auf ein ein Aufblühen unter
multipolaren Vorzeichen eigentlich
erledigt zu sein und die Tendenz geht
wieder zurück die alte Ordnung des 20
Jahrhunderts herzustellen ja und das ist
ja auch irgendwie verständlich dass der
wichtige das wichtige Wort in dem in dem
Satz war aus westlicher Sicht man
versucht natürlich mit aller Kraft das
alte zu halten das hat auch der Adel
versucht es gab nur ganz wenige Adlige
in der Französischen Revolution die sich
auf die Seite der Aufsteiger geschlagen
haben die Mehrheit haben
versucht ihr altes System zu halten und
zu zementieren
und
dieses Slogans des workonomic Forums
haben mich sehr gewundert weil sie
doch weil das wollte Economic Forum
jetzt doch unter Druck sozusagen eben
zeigt was es dann am Ende ist nämlich
doch sozusagen die westliche Sicht es
findet halt in Davos statt
mitten in Europa
die asiatischen Länder Afrika Südamerika
würden das glaube ich die würden das
anders sehen und
da ist auch die Sichtweise auf den
Konflikt USA Russland als ein Konfliktes
Westens
und selbst die Inder sagen das ist euer
Problem wir wollen uns nicht mehr von
auf die eine oder auf die andere Seite
zwingen lassen vom Besten wir wollen uns
nicht zwingen lassen pro russisch oder
gegen Amerika zu sein oder umgekehrt
sondern das ist euer Konflikt wir die
Inder wollen mit allen gute Beziehungen
haben und insofern sieht
die Welt jetzt die unter Druck geraten
ist aus diesen unterschiedlichen
Blickwinkeln sehr sehr unterschiedlich
aus
und die schlauen Adligen die haben
irgendwann den Perspektivwechsel geübt
und haben sich in die aufsteigenden
bürgerschichten hineinversetzt und im
besten Fall haben sie mit ihnen
zusammengearbeitet und ich glaube das
ist der einzige Weg für den Westen so
ein so ein schlauer Adliger war Helmut
Schmidt zum Beispiel da war sozusagen
der der mirabo der späten 20 Jahrhundert
ja der also rechtzeitig die starke
Bedeutung Chinas erkannt hat und der
immer darauf gebracht hat dass man zwar
in Deutschland alles dafür tun sollte
die Einhaltung der Menschenrechte
zu zu wahren und zu B waren und dass er
selbst bereit wäre notfalls auch mit dem
Stock dazwischen zu gehen dass es aber
nicht die Aufgabe des Westens sei andere
Länder in punkto Menschenrechte zu
moralisieren
ist das auch ihre Position oder würden
Sie sagen das hat der Schmidt ein
bisschen arg drastisch ausgedrückt es
ist schon die Aufgabe des Westens auf
China im Hinblick auf die Menschenrechte
zumindestens einzuwirken wenn man die
richtige Sprache spricht
also erstmal hat Helmut Schmidt ja auch
gerne mal provoziert und äh dieser Satz
ist glaube ich auch in dieser Richtung
zu verstehen dass man mal was aufspringt
damit man darüber redet natürlich sollen
wir in dieser neuen Weltordnung und
müssen wir unsere Wertevorstellung
vertreten ja was denn sonst und
natürlich können wir aufgrund von
wirtschaftlichen Interessen unsere Werte
nicht aufgeben ich habe ja eben schon
mal gesagt das ist mit ganz eng
miteinander verbunden die Frage ist nur
unter der entscheidende Punkt ist nur
wir können sie nicht mit Zwingen wir
müssen Sie überzeugen und das ist aber
wieder etwas eigentlich wenn Sie
langfristig die mächtigeren sind also
wir hatten wir haben wenn wir so so
unserem Kompass neu justieren müssen
verstehe ich dass wir erkennen müssen
dass wir am 21 Jahrhundert in einer
anderen Welt leben als um 20 Jahrhundert
im Hinblick auf die Bedeutung
aufstrebende Nation China in aller
erster Stelle Indien vielleicht an
zweiter Stelle vielleicht kommt
irgendwann Iran dazu ja und Indonesien
dass wir also da in einer anderen Welt
leben das ist mir klar aber die die
spannende Frage was bedeutet das im
praktischen Umgang also wenn wir so eine
ganz praktische Frage haben die Chinesen
möchten
ganz groß in den Hamburger Hafen
Einstein so wie sie das in imperious
gemacht haben mit sehr viel Erfolg
wie würden Sie denn jetzt als
hanseatischer Politiker darauf reagieren
würden Sie sagen da besteht keine
Bedrohung oder Gefahr jeder Investor ist
willkommen oder würden Sie sagen der
diskutieren wir erst über Menschenrechte
oder wie muss ich mir das praktisch
vorstellen ja das ist ungefähr praktisch
so wie wenn sie in der FDP sind und eine
bestimmte Überzeugung haben und wissen
aber die FDP ist eine relativ kleine
Partei um ihre Interessen durchzusetzen
brauchen sie Mehrheiten also müssen sie
andere Leute davon überzeugen das machen
wir ja in innerhalb der Demokratien
selbstverständlich und es ist ja das
seltsame
dass wir
das auf internationale Ebene
gewissermaßen ausschließen also wir
werfen ja wir werfen ja den Chinesen vor
dass sie nicht genug Mitbestimmung
zulassen in ihrem Land und die Chinesen
werfen uns vor dass wir nicht genug
Mitbestimmung global zulassen und beides
stimmt
das sozusagen und da kann man nicht
sagen dass eine ist richtig in das
andere ist falsch und wir müssen
akzeptieren dass beide stimmt und wir
müssen lernen dass wir diese
praktikende Mitbestimmung die wir ja in
Demokratien lange eingeübt haben dass
die in Zukunft auch auf globaler Ebene
funktionieren werden oder sich immer
stärker etablieren wird das wird dauern
da reden wir jetzt nicht über fünf Jahre
das sind lange Prozesse aber das wird zu
kommen und wenn wir die Mehrheit der
Chinesen nicht davon überzeugen dann ist
das eben so wie wie in der FDP wenn ich
nicht die SPD und die Grünen äh mit
denen eine Schnittmenge bildet dann
komme ich nicht in die Regierung Punkt
sie haben ja vorhin so eine
Zukunftsperspektive ich nenne mir mal
fuku ja mal Leid entworfen ja also sie
sagen das mit den Werten und den
Menschenrechten und mehr Bestimmung und
ein besseres Leben und so das wird in
China auch alles kommen und das ist auch
schon in Shanghai oder sowas ja links im
Gange wenn die Diskussion geführt oder
wenn jetzt neue neue zukunftsmetropolen
entwickelt werden dann haben die
Menschen schon andere Privilegien oder
auch mehr Freiheitsräume und das
entwickelt sich mehr und mehr in diese
Richtung dagegen gibt es
interessante Spekulationen die sagen
wenn das tatsächlich so sein sollte dass
das chinesische Modell also diese
Mischung aus
wie auch immer verstandenem Kommunismus
auf der einen Seite und
Raubtierkapitalismus auf der anderen
Seite so unglaublich erfolgreich ist und
wenn die Chinesen mit ihrer starken
Partei wo sie die Eliten versammeln
anders als bei uns gehen ja die Eliten
in die Politik ja oder werden die
Politik gezogen was er bei uns eher
weniger der Fall ist wenn das alles so
erfolgreich ist und wenn die damit so
Stratege schon langfristig erfolgreich
sein können Riesenprojekte wie er
seidenstraßenprojekt machen können
wird das nicht Umkehrschluss bedeuten
dass wir von den Chinesen lernen müssen
und uns stärker ein chinesischer
Verhältnisse anpassen müssen und auch
was von China übernehmen müssen ich sage
das deswegen mal vor einigen Jahren ich
auf einer Konferenz war wo ein
hochrangiger Vertreter der deutschen
Wirtschaft dann Verbandsvertreter
gesprochen hat der aus dem Schwärmen
über China gar nicht herauskam ja und
sagte da ist Zucht da und da kann
gemacht werden und langfristig und so
weiter und da geht sowas also es könnte
ja auch in diese Richtung gehen dass
sagen wir mal dass Erfolgsmodell das
wirtschaftliche Erfolgsmodell uns wenn
wir in stärkere wirtschaftliche
Schwierigkeiten kommen sollten als
Ausweg oder Lösung haben sie davor keine
Angst nein warum soll ich denn nicht von
China lernen das heißt ja nicht dass ich
das was mir lieb und teuer ist aufgeben
muss vielleicht gerade schon also
Zivilgesellschaft und möglichst viel
Mitbestimmung bei jedem
bahntrassenprojekt was irgendwo gemacht
wird und chinesische Verhältnisse sind
Widerspruch also lutzerat
Demonstrationen können ich würde mich
gar nicht so lange bei dem Widerspruch
aufhalten sondern ich würde eine
Synthese suchen und die wie kann ganz
einfach sein warum macht man nicht zwei
Jahre Mitbestimmung für alle und jeden
ein bezieht einen möglichst großen Kreis
von Menschen in ein Projekt ein und dann
wird aber eine Entscheidung gefällt und
dann ist Schluss und dann wird diese
Entscheidung umgesetzt das wäre zum
Beispiel sozusagen eine eine Möglichkeit
wo wir von chinesischen
entwicklungsgeschwindigkeiten lernen
ohne unsere Mitbestimmung und ohne
unsere
zivilgesellschaftliche Teilhabe
aufzugeben naja also der große tippen
Komplex an dem sich das entscheiden wird
ist die nachhaltigkeitsfrage also die
dringlicher die ökologischer Revolution
wird wie wie bedrohlicher der
Klimawandel mit seinen Konsequenzen
führt umso mehr ist ja auf der einen
Seite der Wunsch da dass ein starker
Staat möglichst in der Lage ist alle
notwendigen Maßnahmen zu ergreifen um
möglichst viel zu stoppen und
gleichzeitig weiß man wenn ein Staat so
stark wäre dass er das wirklich alles
könnte dann würden wir hier nicht mehr
in einer liberalen Demokratie leben ja
und deswegen kommt ja quasi sozusagen
die chinesische Frage indirekt auf uns
zu ich habe hier mit Robert habe
gesessen der entgegen gegen Gerüchten
die im Internet gestreut werden hier
sehr klar sich für den westlichen weg
und gegen den chinesischen Weg
ausgesprochen wird sie meinen daraus
wäre eine Synthese möglich können Sie
mir das mit einer kurzen Antwort
beantworten zum Schluss ich habe ja die
Synthese gerade beschrieben vielleicht
müssen wir müssen wir dazu kommen
vielleicht ist es ein Fortschritt einer
Demokratie wenn man sagt so große
Mitbestimmung wie möglich aber nur bis
zu einem bestimmten Punkt und dann kann
man nicht mehr klagen dann kann man
nicht mehr den Prozess aufhalten sondern
dann wird ein Projekt umgesetzt und dann
hat man unter Umständen noch die
Möglichkeit oder sicherlich noch die
Möglichkeit die Regierung die das dann
umsetzen
vielleicht ist das ein Weg was mich am
meisten stört ist dass wir gar nicht
wirklich darüber diskutieren sondern
dass wir sagen der Westen ist gut und
China ist schlecht und damit ist die
Sache zementiert und ich glaube wenn wir
das tun
dann Schaden wir uns selbst
und wenn wir nicht mehr danach suchen
unsere Demokratie und unsere
Gesellschaft weiter zu entwickeln und
wenn wir aufhören zu schauen was an
anderen Stellen der Welt an
Entwicklungen gibt was es an anderen
Stellen der Welt dann Entwicklung gibt
dann kommen wir vielleicht in gleiche
Situation wie die Chinese im 19
Jahrhundert die auch geglaubt haben sie
müssen die industrielle Revolution nicht
beachten und dann in eine große Krise
gefahren sind und das ist meine Sorge
wenn wir die Offenheit verlieren dann
kriegen wir ein großes Problem und ein
Stück weit haben wir sie schon verloren
Herren für das Gespräch
[Musik]